it's not just like oh Follow Your
Passion it's a little bit more of like a
complex formula like what are you
interested in what are you passionate
about also like your nature also uh how
can you make money that type of thing
yes looked at
subliminally and logically right another
one of the big things that also affected
me helped me a lot is being able to
connect my logical mind with my
emotional subliminal mind okay
meditation helped me a lot it brings
those two things together and so on but
if you can align what you're emotionally
attracted to which is an extension of
your nature
and you then align that with what you
intellectually say that you should do
and you have those in alignment you're
really good
um like I think
um
somebody might make the mistake of
thinking
success you you asked me about success
and you might say ah it's making a lot
of money or ah it's having a lot of
power or whatever that no that's not
accurate okay
um and that may be you know like
um how does it feel
uh in other words okay money for example
has no intrinsic value it is not in and
of itself something it's only valuable
in the that it buys you what something
okay
pay attention what is that something and
what is it that it's satisfying is it
Freedom that abides you is it security
that it buys you uh is it status that
it's buying you what is it that is the
underlying thing that's mine that is
pulling you in that direction and if you
know those things and you guide yourself
both intellectually and emotionally and
then when they're both in alignment and
you go in that direction you will make
the discoveries and the choices so it's
not so much different from thinking
about let's say what food you might eat